you do not give a bloody damn about your
brothers and sisters I have a
six-year-old I have a 2-year-old I have
a two Monon year old baby anytime every
time I pick them up and I think to
myself Subhan Allah imagine I'm holding
them and they have been blown into
pieces do you not have kids you
Shameless person how dare you come out
and tell us not to boycott the least
that we can
[Music]
do
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends uh I'm at an event today in
Sheffield and I'm quite busy uh but
Subhan Allah I saw this video of this
individual and I don't even want to
mention him by name I'm trying my best
not to mention him by name and I just
asked the brother z may Allah bless him
to just hold the camera because I was
thinking to myself how could anybody in
their right mind how could anybody who
has an atom weight of rahma Mercy like
Allah says in the Quran the Believers
are those who are soft to one another
and harsh towards the enemies how is it
possible I just it just my mind stops at
the thought of how could it be possible
that you put your camera up and so
comfortably and so confidently which
you're going to see the clip now mention
the following guys let's watch it for
ourself and you guys will be as shocked
as I am country when you when you go to
the public and say hey guys everyone we
should boycott so and so so and so
company what I had to deal with that
company they're paying us and when we
have a deal together you're ruining that
deal and it's up to the to the Muslim
government that you cannot disobey it
like that if the Muslim government or
the ruler says boycott then yes because
he he knows things you don't know and
they have agreements they have taken
care of it so now he says okay to
boycott and it happened before but if it
doesn't happen now meaning that we don't
know something it's going to harm us if
we boycott them yeah so boycotting
that's why many of the they said
boycotting is har it's not up to you
it's not up the deal is between the
government or the the the government
agency like you know the municipality or
the department of economy or whatever
they had a deal with so and so company
you come and say to the people yeah
don't buy from them why who are you what
Authority do you have it's not allowed
oh guys you heard that for yourself can
you imagine guys the prophet wasam told
us if you see evil try to stop it with
your hands try to stop it if you cannot
do that and says this could be that if
you are a government like if you have
power no problem try to stop with your
hands if you can't do it we know we
cannot do that it's hard for us to do
that no problem speak out against
it this varris
guy W it's as if if you had the power
with your hand you would not stop it let
alone talk about it and I've asked you
many times why do you not condemn forget
condemn insult ask for Allah subhana and
the Zionist not the Jews the Zionist
government Israel you don't you refuse
to no problem and we know why you don't
we know why you don't we know where you
live and we know your comfort your comfy
sofa and your comfortable uh lifestyle
is more important no problem you cannot
do that now he's coming out and telling
us the little that we have not just
hating it in the heart that the prophet
said which we do but at least we can say
we can stop buying certain products and
boycott now he's telling you you cannot
even do that let alone asking Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to end this government
who is oppressing the innocent
Palestinians you don't do that now he's
telling us that when I go to a
supermarket and there is a product that
is there and I'm like I don't want to
buy that product because the blood of my
brothers and sisters is probably there
because I'll be playing a party it by
buying it cuz it supports this
government these oppresses vums he is
telling you you cannot do that who gave
you this ruling which government body
told you that this ruler decides this
that means that I in the UK have to
follow it somebody else said is there a
is there one ruler do we have we don't
have that how do you not have an atom
weight of Mercy their your brothers and
sisters babies are being blown into
pieces and you have not shame you got
white beard I said before in another
video do you not have an atter way of
shame that you are you have the audacity
the confidence with a little smirking
face to come and tell us that now we
cannot to be on the manh may Allah
destroy you your your manage we are not
upon your manage we are not upon your
vile disgusting manage yeah do to hell
with your man you are now telling me you
are now telling me that I cannot boycot
and ref refuse to buy a product I'm
going to be like you know what Ferris
told us that I'm like oh you know I have
to buy it now to Hell may Allah subhana
tala guide you and I ask Allah subhana
if not to guide you may Allah subhana
deal with you because you do not give a
bloody Dam about your brothers and
sisters I have a six-year-old I have a
2-year-old I have a two monthy old baby
anytime every time I pick them up and I
think to myself Subhan Allah imagine I'm
holding them and they have been blown
into pieces do you not have kids you
shame person how dare you come out and
tell us not to boycott the least that we
can do what are you going to do when I
if I do a video saying people to boycot
what are you going to do next um this
guy he's not on the man of the
salf W if you didn't have white beard I
will spit on the camera W you know
you're white beard you are Elder but let
me tell you something I am trying to
show utmost respect you deserve this
minimum shame on you w you where's your
video condemning Israel one statement
man I dare you say may Allah destroy him
the Zionist government we're not asking
about the Jews we have no problem with
the Jewish Community we are talking
about a group of people who are
oppressing another just like those
people who the West condemn Russia no
problem what about them they're doing
exactly the same thing
worse may Allah subh deal with you you
do not have a heart your heart is dead
and I'm not talking Iman wise I'm not
talking about belief wise Mercy wise w
may Allah subhana tala notest what they'
being tested one thing I'll end on like
Allah subh says in the Quran to B is
when he told them not to fish in the
Sabbath the scholars say that when Allah
destroyed the ones who fished in the
Sabbath Allah also destroyed the ones
who were silent the ones who were silent
the silent Devils who were there he were
watching it happen and they were quiet
and Allah subhana wa tala also destroyed
them we're not going to be amongst them
we're going to be among those who
enjoying good and forid evil inah we
should not only boycott Israel we should
boycott you your true colors have been
there from day one people think I have a
problem personal problem with you I have
personal problem with you I have a
problem with your morality with your
that you have zero that as if Allah subh
is taken
away till next
time the prophet sallu alh wasallam said
whoever builds a Masid for the sake of
Allah subhana tala Allah will build for
him a similar house in jenah on that day
where Allah subhana tala tells us that
our books will be given and every little
atam weight of Good Deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
oh